die schweiz und die eu tun sich schwer
mit einander an einen beitritt war nie
zu denken
und nun ist auch der bilaterale weg
lange als königsweg gehandelt unter
beschuss doch die kritik kommt nicht nur
aus der schweiz
wie erklärt sich das schwindende
vertrauen in die union
welchen stellenwert genießen die
personenfreizügigkeit und die nationale
souveränität und welche rolle spielt
europa in der welt von morgen
diese fragen diskutieren heute nicht
wieder an reding der ehemaligen
vizepräsidentin der europäischen
kommission und derzeitigen eu
parlamentarierin aus luxemburg nieding
im februar dieses jahres hat die schweiz
ja gesagt zu einer massiven
einschränkung der personenfreizügigkeit
also der zuwanderung auch außer ihnen
vor kurzem hat sie nein gesagt so einer
noch viel massiveren einschränkung der
zuwanderung wie bewerten sie dieses
ergebnis eine erleichterung ich glaube
die schweiz ist auf dem weg des
vernünftigen jetzt müssen wir dann sehen
wie wir unsere bilateralen verbindungen
verbessern indem man den grundelementen
der europäischen verträge und dem willen
des schweizer volkes rechnung trägt das
ist eine herausforderung die auch wir in
der schweiz hier kennen sie selbst
bleiben wir moment noch bei ihrer person
sie haben eine vorliebe für den dichter
rainer maria rilke woher wissen sie das
denn
ja wenn man sucht dann findet man so
einfach ist das heute
und sie haben sich sie haben auch eine
ferienwohnung kommentare also im wallis
wo sich auch linke niedergelassen hat
mögen sie die schweiz
ich mag die schweiz enorm ich bin schon
als kleinkind mit meinen eltern
regelmäßig in wallis gekommen
und als ich dann selbst mutter wurde
fand ich dass es keinen besseren
ferienort für das aufziehen meiner söhne
ist gibt als den wallis also haben wir
solange meine jungs klein waren die
ferien im wallis verbracht sie haben
aber in ihrem leben ja nicht nur ferien
verbracht sondern sehr viel gearbeitet
sie haben es gesagt ich glaube im fall
ist kann man doch auch arbeiten mit dem
schönen blick über die berge
das ist inspiration
sehr schön war es auch inspiration für
die politische arbeit ja sehr oft dann
in der politischen arbeit muss man ja
manchmal einen schritt zurück sich
hinsetzen und überlegen nachdenken
und dafür braucht man ausgeglichenheit
das kann man nicht im hektischen leben
immer machen
sie sehen ja mit 28 in die
luxemburgische politik eingestiegen mit
38 in die europäische wann war für sie
klar dass sie in diesen neuen europa
eine wichtige rolle einnehmen wollen
oder es war relativ schnell klar
ich habe zuerst meine lehrjahre
absolviert und zwar in der lokalpolitik
war im gemeinderat meiner stadt und in
der nationalen politik im nationalen
parlament und dann habe ich sehr schnell
verstanden dass in luxemburg ja
innenpolitik europapolitik ist und dass
wenn man etwas bewirken will für seinen
staat wenn man die spezifizität dieses
kleinen landes bei halten will
dass man dann sich in europa engagieren
muss und deshalb bin ich dann den
schritt nach europa gegangen
gilt das nur für luxemburg und das gilt
vor allem für kleine länder und das gilt
heute für auch die großen die noch immer
nicht verstanden haben dass sie klein
sind
denn wir leben in einer globalisierten
welt und in dieser globalisierten welt
geht es auf augenhöhe mit den anderen
kontinenten
und wer seine eigenständigkeit seine
kulturelle vielfalt beibehalten will der
muss auf augenhöhe sein um seine
spezifizität 'nen auch durchsetzen zu
können
ganz zur europäerin sie waren ja zehn
jahre im parlament dann 15 jahre in der
kommission
sie war am schluss eben vizepräsidentin
der kommission
sie haben ihren weg alleine gemacht um
es so zu sagen
und sie haben trotzdem für eine
frauenquote gekämpft wie passt das
zusammen weil man am ende des weges
versteht dass es leider ohne hilfsmittel
nicht geht und es war sehr interessant
diese frauenquote ist ja gewollt worden
von vielen vorn und von vielen frauen
die es selbst fertig gebracht haben und
die eigentlich nie eine quote wollten
wenn sie mir vor 20 jahren gesagt hätten
eine quote hätte ich gesagt ach quatsch
und heute sage ich ganz einfach mir
gefällt die quote nicht aber mir gefällt
was die quote bewirkt nämlich dass diese
gläserne decke durchbrochen wird und
dass die weiblichen talente über die
redet man ja die frauen die wollen die
frauen die können die frauen die einen
beitrag leisten können dass die einmal
zugang haben
dieser zugang ist ihnen sehr oft leider
heute erschwert er wert und deshalb gilt
es den zu ermöglichen freue sie dass die
schweiz nachziehen
also ich glaube jede wir hatten jäger
werden nachziehen
es ist bewegung in die ganze sache
gekommen als ich von europäischer seite
aus ein europäisches gesetzesvorhaben
auf den tisch gelegt hat daher gab es
sehr viele bewegung in allen
mitgliedstaaten es haben sich sehr viele
frauen verbände gegründet von frauen von
juristinnen von ingenieuren von
ärztinnen von journalistinnen die
geholfen haben das durchzusetzen das war
eine gemeinschaftsarbeit und zwar
überall und ich bin so stolz auf die
frauen dass wir das herzig gebracht
haben dann sind sie auch zufrieden mit
den ersten resultaten
langsam langsam kommt es es war wirklich
eine aufbauarbeit zoey generis denn am
anfang waren ja alle dagegen
und wir waren aber so ein dutzend frauen
aus mehreren staaten alle auf höchster
ebene und die gesagt haben jetzt machen
wir es gegen die mauer rennen
jan und heute können wir einen mauerfall
sehr schön
kommen wir zurück zur schweiz und diese
zu dieser abstimmung die kürzlich
stattgefunden hat das nein zur
sp-initiative können sie können sie die
zurückhaltung der schweiz nachvollziehen
können sie nachvollziehen dass die
schweiz sagen wir im februar ja gesagt
hat dass die schweiz versucht sich zu
wehren gegen diese zuwanderung nein gar
nicht wir haben einen ausländeranteil
von 25 luxemburg hat 44 das ist richtig
46 46 inzwischen ja und wenn wir dann
aber die umliegenden länder an die
nachbarländer der schweiz sind wir bei
in österreich bei elf prozent das geht
dann runter bis frankreich bei 6 prozent
da ist die schweiz mit
die kleine schweiz mit 25 prozent doch
wesentlich höher und diese 25 prozent
sind ja nicht leichtfertig verteilt die
nicht schweizer sitzen ja omas auf
verschiedenen orten und andere orte sind
nicht schweizer leer
eigentlich so dass man auch da wieder
differenzieren muss interessant ist ja
wenn man sich die wenn man analysiert
wie abgestimmt wurde
dort wo es fehle nicht schweizer gibt
ist man positiv und dort wo man allein
auf weiter flur ist ist man negativ auch
interessant soziologisch analysiert wie
wird sie es erklären wenn die menschen
sehen wie man mit anderen menschen
zusammen arbeiten zusammen leben
zusammen integrieren kann
dann ist diese furcht nicht mehr da
jetzt ist es ja nicht so dass die
schweiz es ein zählern ist das mühe hat
mit der personenfreizügigkeit mehr
erleben derzeit aus england ja einen
massiven vor kein massives vorgehen auch
gegen die ihn das ja bis hin zur
austrittsdrohungen geht können sie das
nachvollziehen das ist reine nationale
politik und das können sie nachfolgenden
allen mitgliedstaaten wo es diese links
oder rechtsextreme gibt übrigens die die
haben genau dieselbe sprache ops
linksextreme oder rechtsextrem
ich mache da wenig unterschied
wenn es in einem staat wirtschaftlich
nicht mehr so gut geht wenn nachts ein
aufkommen
die die etablierten parteien ankratzen
sich gegen die aufstellen
dann nehmen manchmal die etablierten
parteien die flucht nach vorne an und
versuchen diese extrem rechten zum
beispiel rechts zu überholen
das sieht man in frankreich jetzt sehr
klar wo der neue führer der ump sarkozy
ja noch schlimmeres sagt als leben
das sieht man auch sehr deutlich dann in
großbritannien wo kamera der hat
nächstes jahr eine wahl und die ukip die
gewinnt wahlen im derzeit versucht die
ukip rechts zu überholen also aus meiner
erfahrung 35 jahren in der politik sage
ich ihnen menschen wählen wenn sie
vertrauen haben und wenn sie zwischen
einem original und einer kopie zu wählen
haben wählen sie immer das original also
rechts überholen ist meiner meinung nach
ein sehr schlechte entscheidung
was wäre die alternative die alternative
ist klar zu sagen wo sind das stete
probleme und so lösen für sie bleiben
wir noch einen moment in der schweiz
diese probleme werden ja hier
wahrgenommen und die frage ist eben auch
wie lösen wir sie und letztlich
versuchen hat die schweiz nun ja gesagt
zu einer zu einer initiative die sagt
wir wollen weniger von dieser
zuwanderung und diese initiative das
wissen wir inzwischen dass mussten wir
eigentlich auch schon vorstellen
letztlich diesen bilateralen weg auch
ein stück weit in die frage in frage sie
haben schon 2012 gesagt dass sie den
bilateralen weg ich zitiere für
undurchsichtig bürokratisch und nicht
mehr zeitgemäß halten
meinen sie damit ich meine damit dass es
so nicht weitergehen wird
europa hat sich seit den bilateralen weg
mit der schweiz sehr stark entwickelt es
ist zu einem kontinent geworden viele
stehen im wartesaal und vollen 1
wir machen in diesem augenblick eine
beitritts pause aber sonderwege wird es
nicht mehr geben
und trotzdem sind sie sie haben es ja
vorher gesagt zuversichtlich dass man
dieses problem und lösen kann
also man muss einige sachen ja etwas aus
deutsche zuerst einmal was heißt
zuwanderung auch bei uns gibt es
menschen die zu wandeln und dann eine
belastung für die sozialsysteme werden
ganz einfach weil die regeln nicht
eingehalten werden die freizügigkeit in
europa heißt dass man zu wandern kann
die freizügigkeit gebrauchen kann um in
ferien zu gehen um stück zu studieren
oder um zu arbeiten nicht um keine
möglichkeiten zu haben sich und seine
familie zu ernähren und auf last der
aufgebauten systeme zu fallen also
einwanderung zur arbeit ja einwanderung
in die sozialsysteme nein so steht es
auch klar und deutlich in den
europäischen gesetzen uhr werden diese
gesetze aus mannigfaltigen ursachen
nicht immer in die praxis übersetzt von
den nationalstaaten und dann kommt das
zu den problemen und dann wird anstatt
auf sich selbst zu zeigen ich habe als
staat meine aufgabe nicht erfüllt wird
dann auf brüssel gezeigt dass ich dir
einfach die sind dann immer die
buhmänner
wenn es zu hause nicht klappt jetzt hat
der europäische gerichtshof kürzlich
entschieden dass eben die dass diese das
gegen die gegen den sozialtourismus
sowohl das auch genannt dass gegen den
gesetzlich vorgegangen
man kann ist das nun ein entgegenkommen
gegenüber den eu kritikern oder ist das
eine quasi eine impfpflicht name der
mitgliedstaaten diese europäische
gerichtshof ist ja eine institution die
ich liebe
da sitzen nämlich und schon seit
jahrzehnten sehr verständige richter und
richterinnen und die entscheiden
aufgrund der europäischen verträge die
tut nichts mehr und nicht minder als
erklären was denn da wirklich drin steht
und manchmal braucht man dem gerichtshof
um klar und deutlich das zu sagen was
auf dem papier steht zum beispiel
freizügigkeit da hatten die briten ein
problem
1974 mit schon damals und da sagte der
gerichtshof 1974 ja die freizügigkeit
muss im nationalen kontext auf
arbeitnehmer angewandt klärt und heute
wiederum sagt die der gerichtshof dass
evidente ja es steht explizit in den
europäischen verträgen dass es keine
zuwanderung in sozialsysteme gibt und
dass bei missbrauch der freizügigkeit
auch genannt werden kann also das steht
alles in den texten der gerichtshof hat
nichts anderes gesagt als das was in den
texten steht also gibt der gerichtshof
die verantwortung an die mitgliedstaaten
zurück absolut und da liegt sie ja auch
weil wir ja den mitgliedstaaten
überlassen
regeln zu entwerfen die nicht
diskriminierend sind man darf ja nicht
diskriminieren zwischen europäischen
bürgern aber die missbrauch ernten und
missbrauch muss geahndet werden
es kann ja nicht so sein dass menschen
die steuern zahlen
damit das system funktioniert dann sehen
wie dieses system ausgehebelt wird durch
menschen die die profiteure spielen das
und darf nicht sein weder in einem staat
noch in einem staaten geflügel wie die
europäische union
glauben sie dass dieses urteil wirkung
erzielen wird ja ich hoffe dass jetzt
endlich verstanden wird dass es eine
verantwortung gibt auf nationaler ebene
und dass die auch einzuführen ist ich
hatte vor eineinhalb jahren die
innenminister zusammengerufen und hatte
ihnen genau dasselbe gesagt nur das ging
zu einem rein zum anderen raus und dann
gingen sie nach hause und machten
weiterhin nichts jetzt hat der
gerichtshof ja dasselbe gesagt
hoffentlich wird er jetzt gehört sie
hoffen immer noch sie können immer noch
nicht mit sicherheit sagen man weiß es
ja nie also politik ist was kompliziert
ist und wenn das 28 mal ist wie in der
europäischen union können sie ja
vorstellen dass es doch komplizierter
ist aber genau deshalb gefällt mir ja
sonst wäre es ja langweilig und deshalb
bin ich ja in die europa politik
gegangen das ist ja sowas wird spannend
rund 20 verschiedenen nationen mit
anderen sprachen mit anderen kulturen
und zusammen versuchen wir ein kontinent
aufzubauen wo die kulturelle vielfalt
geprägt wird und geschützt wird herrlich
aber jetzt haben sie ja gerade in
triesen interessanten gegensatz wahl
gestellt zwischen diesen vielen ländern
mitgliedstaaten sich diesen 28 ländern
und kulturen einerseits und der tatsache
dass sie fein sind vom europäischen
gerichtshof wenn ich das so wieder geben
darf und das interessante daran ist ja
dass jetzt das gerichtshof entscheidet
ist richterinnen und richter die
entscheiden per gesetz die setzen so
durch und der andere weg wäre ja die
politik die sich durch sieht die
entscheiden durch über urteilen
aufgrund einer fertig so monti
verfassung wird von den politikern
gemacht die farce um die verträge die
gesetze die gesetze kommen ja aus der
verfassung oder aus den verträgen also
die richter erfinde nichts neues die
sage nur was sache ist
aber sie sagen eigentlich dass die
mitglied stände mitgliedsländer diesen
gerichtshof brauchen damit sie wirklich
das machen was sie einmal
bestimmt haben ja ich das sehr manchmal
bedarf es einer konfirmation vom
gerichtshof damit damit auch alles
verstanden haben jetzt hat ja auch die
schweiz einen bezug oder eben einen
schwierigen bezug zu diesem europäischen
gerichtshof es geht ja um die
verhandlungen über das institutionelle
rahmenabkommen
sie selber haben auch 2012 schon gesagt
dass die schweiz lange von dieser
einwanderung profitiert hat dass der
bilaterale weg ebenso zu ende ist als
dass man irgendeinen montag ist bei den
bilateralen geht es ja nicht nur um
einwanderung übrigens einwanderung
gebrauchen wir in europa für menschen
die aus drittstaaten kommen
eintritt statt oder ist nein die drei
die schweiz ist kein drittstaat in dem
sinne ein drittstaat wäre marokko zum
beispiel oder die türkei wir reden von
freizügigkeit unsere menschen haben das
recht auf freizügigkeit und die europäer
sehen dieses recht auch als eines der
wichtigen elemente die sie aus europa
bekommen haben also die europäer lieben
die freizügigkeit 68 prozent der
europäer sagen das ist die wichtigste
freiheit die europa ihnen gebracht hat
und dann geht es ja nicht nur um
freizügigkeit von menschen es geht ja
auch um freizügigkeit von gütern von
kapital von dienstleistungen und ich
brauche ja jetzt nicht zu erklären
inwieweit die eingekesselte schweiz von
dieser freizügigkeit profitiert
eingekesselt klingt aber relativ
bedrohlich wäre ich würde mich als
bedroht fühlen wenn ich weiß wäre auch
wenn die berge schützen
aber schauen sie sich mal eine landkarte
an die karte europas und da gibt es so
in der mitte so ein kleiner weißer fleck
glauben sie dass die schweiz nicht
bedroht fühlt ich weiß aus nämlich haben
sich versuchen die andere perspektive
gottseidank bedrohen wir ja nicht
sondern wir sind ja ein kontinent
der sich öffnet und deshalb ist auch die
philosophie und die symbolik dieser
freizügigkeit so wichtig und deshalb
werden wie die auch nicht anpacken
die werden wir werden daran nicht
rütteln das ist einer der
basisfunktionen dieses kontinents und
wie er zusammen gewachsen ist dieser
kontinent
daran wird nicht gerüttelt jetzt steht
die schweiz aber trotzdem in
verhandlungen mit der europäischen union
ja was sollte denn auch anders machen
die hat ja die verträge die sie
ratifiziert hat unterschrieben hat
einseitig aufgekündigt aufkündigen
müssen wegen volksentscheiden glauben
sie denn dass man in diesen
verhandlungen stück weiter kommt dass
die schweiz die eu da eine gute lösung
finden
ja ich hoffe dass die schweiz mit
vorschlägen kommt die nicht gegen die
europäischen verträge sind was würden
sie der schweiz sagen um sie nach meine
ich wörtlich schreibt also die schweiz
hat ja gute minister und hoffentlich
werden die das ei des kolumbus dann auch
finden wenn sie es findet dies sind die
eu bereit sich darauf einzulassen wenn
es nicht gegen eu verträge geht und die
freizügigkeit in den eu verträgen ist
quasi heilig ein großes wort
schauen wir doch diese heiligen
institutionen an ihr wollt den
gerichtsverfahren wir bereits gesprochen
wir haben da einmal ein bild aus dem
eu-parlament über 700 abgeordnete aus
den 28 mitgliedsstaaten und wir haben
ein bild auf der kommission eine
kommissionssitzung zwei institutionen
der eu neben dem eu-rat in dem die
staatschefs der eu mitgliedsstaaten
bringen sind viele menschen kennen diese
institution ja nicht ganz genau was muss
man über die kommission und was muss man
über das parlament wissen eigentlich ist
das eigentlich ist es sehr einfach
das sieht sich schrecklich kompliziert
an aber es ist ein zwei kammern system
die kommission ist die regierung die
macht vorschläge und diese vorschläge
gegen gehen dann in die zwei kammern in
die das europäische parlament frei
gewählt direkt gewählt von den bürgern
europas und in den europäischen
ministerrat wo aus jedem mitgliedsstaat
ein minister setzt also ein become er
alles system wie in der schweiz könnte
man sagen das parlament ist der
nationalrat und der eu rat ist ein wenig
der ständerat wenn er nach ganz alten
musste nach seinem schweren gefährt so
ungefähr
oder wie in deutschland den bundestag
und den bundesrat und beide zusammen
müssen sich einst werden damit ein
gesetz gesetzt werden kann
also die die entscheidung über ein
gesetz
die liegt beim parlament und beim
ministerrat gemeinsam sie haben beide
institutionen erlebt die waren in beiden
drin sind jetzt wieder im parlament was
gefällt ihnen denn besser wenn man
mitglied einer regierung ist dann gibt
man seine völlige freiheit auf auch wenn
ich immer versucht habe mir ein kleines
bisschen freiheit zu erhalten
aber wenn man im parlament ist hat man
ja eine absolute freiheit und ich
genieße im augenblick diese absolute
freiheit
schauen sie die institution noch etwas
genauer an das vertrauen in die eu sind
ja eigentlich seit zehn jahren
kontinuierlich also die kurve in dem was
gemessen wird die hat zwar schwankungen
drin aber die richtung ist eindeutig es
war mal bei knapp 60 prozent der
bevölkerung die großes vertrauen in
diese institution hat und ist heute
unter 40 prozent sie sich also ich
erkläre mir also man muss ja das ganze
bild sich anschauen wenn es nur das wäre
wäre es nicht so schlimm aber das
vertrauen in die nationalen parlamenten
und in den nationalen regierungen
geht auch nach unten und legt unter dem
vertrauen in die europäische union
also wir haben ein problem der
demokratie ganz einfach und das macht
mir sorgen
ich sehe ja auch dass wir bei den jungen
menschen nicht mehr dieselbe dieselbe
feuer finden um sich politisch zu
engagieren
und das macht mir wirklich sorgen wir
sehen ja auch dass bei der
wahlbeteiligung es auch nicht so gut
geht weder auf bei lokalen wahlen noch
bei nationalen wahlen noch bei
europäischen werden hier bei ihnen in
der schweiz sind ja auch weniger als 50
prozent der menschen die zu den wahlen
schreiten also wenn die leute allerdings
keine kontinuierlich sinkende
beteiligung sondern quasi schwankt mit
der bedeutung der vorlage also sie
bewegt sich immer um die 30 40
ja das ist ja demokratisch nicht gut
finde ist jeden künstler aber wenn es
wirklich wichtig ist gehen wir so aber
wir haben keine tendenz wir haben in
luxemburg die sache in dem sinne gelöst
dass wir wahlpflicht haben
ich finde das gut weil ich die sanktion
muss man bezahlen hat die sanktion ist
steht auf dem papier wird eigentlich
nicht in die praxis umgesetzt
trotzdem hat sich bei den bürgern
eingebürgert dass man sowohl geht und
ich finde das richtig wichtig deshalb
fragen wir aber auch nicht die menschen
alle sechs monate zur wahl zu gehen
wir machen das alle fünf jahre und dann
müssen sie gehen und dann hat man auch
ein wahlresultat was der wirklichkeit
entspricht und wo man wirklich sagen
kann jetzt haben die menschen
entschieden weil eben über 90 prozent
ihre wahlpflicht ausüben
das wäre jetzt eine lange diskussion ob
wir in der schweiz wenn wir vier mal im
jahr zu ohne gehen und europa ist und
welches resultat hätten ich glaube diese
diskussion da würde ich da würde ich
jetzt im gegen halten daher richtig
ich komme ja nicht weg in der schweiz
ist zu dieser frage aber weil ich sehe
dass in sämtlichen mitgliedstaaten die
wahlbeteiligung
und deshalb haben wir ja in europa jetzt
etwas neues versucht die sache mit den
spitzenkandidaten wofür die
präsidentschaft also für die die
präsidentschaft der regierung jede
parteien familie einen spitzenkandidaten
festlegt und die parteien familie die
gewinnt dies stellt an den präsidenten
der kommission diesmal die
christdemokraten mit jean claude juncker
warum machen wir das eben um wir haben
ja gemerkt dass wenn man nicht eine
personalisierung der wahlen hat oder wie
sie sagen bei ihren barrieren mutation
etwas für die menschen sich sehr
angesprochen fühlen
dann gehen die menschen nicht zu weil
das sehen wir in vielen mitgliedstaaten
und wir haben uns ein beispiel genommen
an amerika was sehr interessant ist in
den vereinigten staaten wenn es nur die
midterms sind also es wird nur parlament
gewählt dann liegt die wahlbeteiligung
so bei 38 40 prozent wenn gleichzeitig
präsidentschaftswahlen sind geht's auf
58 oder über 60 prozent rauf also ich
glaube man sollte schon zu dieser
personalisierung greifen um damit die
menschen wirklich wissen wer vertritt
uns dann dort wo es starke kandidaten
gibt und wo es persönlichkeiten gibt die
in die europa wahlen gehen gegen demand
gehen die menschen auch mehr zur wahl
als dort wo man einfach eine parteien
lösung getroffen hat die wählen ja
eigentlich da den die deutlich den weg
geben des prominenten vertreters oder
der prominenten vertreterinnen während
sich ja auch bald irgendwann mal eine
frau sein die da ins rennen kommt wärst
du sozusagen der ich sagen der weg der
schweiz wäre jetzt quasi stärker an die
direkte demokratie zu gehen sind ja
umfragen auch im september dieses jahres
wurde das veröffentlicht das sich
bürgeln bürger eine stärkere beteiligung
wünschen unter anderem auch mit mit mit
meinungsplattform aber auch mit
initiativen und volksabstimmung
man könnte sagen dass sowieso die zwei
extra
um die demokratie zu stärken ende der
wir holen wirklich die bürgerinnen und
bürger mit volksinitiativen und
volksabstimmungen oder wir portieren
spitzenkandidaten die ganz für sie nicht
ein wenig ein widerspruch nein wir haben
in europa ein parlamentarisches system
wie wir übrigens empfehlen unseren
mitgliedstaaten auch haben also bei uns
ist das kernstück der demokratie die
direkt gewählten vertreter des volkes im
parlament und die treffen die richtigen
entscheidungen
das ist ein system von vielen möglichen
und das haben wir nun einfach mal
gewählt
ich glaube aber dass dieses system nicht
ohne ausschluss des volkes geht erst
einmal das volk mischt damit indem es
seine volksvertreter welt oder wieder
abfällt und zweitens wir haben ja
integriert in unsere gesetzgebung
systematik die anhörungen man kann bei
uns nicht ein gesetz abstimmen bevor
ganz weit gefächerte anhörung
stattgefunden haben sowohl auf
wirtschaftlicher ebene als auch auf
ebene der organisierten
zivilgesellschaft ist in der schweiz das
sogenannte vernehmlassungsverfahren wir
haben dass die bewegung ja dass das
drücken wir wirklich durch und ich
versuche jetzt als parlamentarierin
diese dreifache erfahrung die ich
gesammelt habe über ein langes
politisches leben die nationale
parlamentarierin die
europaparlamentarierin und die
ministerin wenn sie so wollen
und ich versuche das zusammenzufügen bin
berichterstatterin zu einem der großen
wirtschafts handelsabkommens der zukunft
und werde in dem sinne auch viele
veranstaltungen machen wo ich das
europaparlament mit den nationalen
europäischen parlamenten zusammensetze
somit den spezialisten in den nationalen
parlamenten die sich um diese materie
kümmern damit wir zusammen dann auch
dieses zusammen
etwas aufbauen und dann in den
mitgliedstaaten das mache ich auch sehr
oft mich mit den fonds wir nennen wir
das den wendigen kreft den lebendigen
kräften zusammensetze ich glaube das
muss man tun und da muss man dann auch
das predigen aufgeben politiken aufgeben
ja politiker predigen zu verkünden dass
das wort
ich glaube man muss zuhören kann man
muss diskutieren kann
das war auch etwas was mir gefehlt hat
in der europa politik übrigens in den
meisten politikern und ich habe deshalb
vor zwei jahren zweieinhalb jahren habe
ich die townhall meetings organisiert
große bürgerversammlungen zu 50 haben
wir gemacht überall in europa wo
politiker hingehen und keine reden
halten frage antwort frage antwort zwei
stunden da lernt man was und die
menschen sehen da ist jemand der zuhört
da ist jemand der auf mich zu geht und
versucht zu verstehen was ich eigentlich
meine und ich lerne über die art und
weise wie die fragen gestellt werden
also man muss mehrere dinge miteinander
kombinieren und insbesondere in europa
das ist ja nicht etwas was nur in
brüssel gemacht werden kann
das muss auch vor ort in den nationalen
stellen in den regionen in den städten
in den davongemacht wachen werden und
das ganze ist ein zusammenarbeit werk
das von vielen getragen wird ist es
nicht eine typisch weibliche art politik
zu machen ich denke an hillary clinton
die auch die orgel ihn hat in erster
linie ich denke auch an schweizerinnen
in den kantonalen und nationalen
parlamenten die auch die für exekutiv
positionen sich kandidieren die einfach
sagen ich muss mit den leuten sprechen
ja typisch also sie haben absolut recht
es war interessant zu sehen dass männer
hören sich gerne reden und frauen sind
zu zuhörern dass ich jetzt sehr
pauschalisiert das kann sich jetzt hier
kein mann verteidigen also in der regel
ist es schon so ich mit mir ist immer
aufgefallen wenn man in einem partei
gremium zum beispiel eine mehrheit von
männern sitzen hat und frauen eigentlich
nicht zum zuge kommen
dauern die sitzungen zwei stunden länger
wenn man einige frauen dabei hat wird
das alles gehofft und die sitzungen
dauer nicht mehr so lange weil die
frauen ja auch noch etwas anderes zu tun
haben möchte ist in eine frauenquote für
das europäische parlament und den
europäischen rat die europäische
kommission die parteien müssen das
rechte in meiner partei in bei den
christdemokraten in luxemburg haben wir
auf parteien ebene schon vor mehr als 15
jahren eine frauenquote eingeführt und
das hat uns gut getan weil wir noch mal
bei der demokratie wer müsste denn diese
demokratie in europa befördern
alle die verantwortung tragen politische
verantwortung tragen und wie ich ja
schon gesagt habe das ist nicht ein ein
dutzend leute in brüssel sondern das ist
auf allen ebenen der politik das geht
bei der lokalen politikern über die
nationale politik auf die europapolitik
ich sage immer bei mir zuhause
luxemburger politik ist europapolitik
und europapolitik ist luxemburger
politik beide kann man ja überhaupt
nicht mehr voneinander trennen
60 70 80 prozent der gesetze die in
luxemburg luxemburger gesetzt werden
wurden in europa entschieden und deshalb
versuche ich ja auch die nationalen
parlamente mehr und mehr einzubinden
das macht sinn also wenn das mal
verstanden wird dann wird die politik
erklärung vor ort auch anders laufen
denn dann ist es nicht mehr die da
hinten haben das gemacht sondern werde
es sein wir zusammen haben das gemacht
gut oder schlecht da müssen wir aber
auch unseren mann oder unsere frau
stehen um das ganze verteidigen zu
erklären
und gegebenenfalls den hut zu nehmen
genau so trocken denn denn mehr
demokratie hieße ja in jedem fall auch
machtverzicht brüssel müsse macht
abgeben an die mitgliedsstaaten an die
bevölkerung die mitgliedstaaten müssen
macht und spielraum abgeben nach brüssel
und die bevölkerung bekommt mehr macht
wer ist zu diesen macht wer ist zu
dieser macht abgabe bereit also um es
ganz salopp zu sagen
die sache ist schon längst entschieden
wir europäer haben jetzt in 60 jahren
aufbau der europäischen union sehr klar
gesehen dass es mit nationalen
entscheidungen nicht mehr reicht das
letzte mal wo wir versucht haben diese
nationalen entscheidungen einzubauen
und das war bei dem maastrichter vertrag
als wir die währungsunion schufen gut
und was geschah die währungsunion wurde
geschaffen wir haben einen euro
geschaffen aber keinen finanzen
finanzminister
das heißt wir haben eine gemeinsame
währung geschaffen uns aber nicht die
instrumente gegeben
diese gemeinsame währung zu begleiten
dann kam die krise
dann saßen wir im dreck und wir mussten
schnell schnell schnell die fehlenden
maßnahmen die fehlenden instrumente
schaffen
spätestens dann haben alle verstanden
dass man nicht eine gemeinsame politik
ohne gemeinsame instrumente schaffen
kann dann muss man es sein lassen
aber wer a sagt muss auch b sagen wir
haben ja gesagt und wir entwickeln uns
stetig leise schritt für schritt in eine
föderation dc generis ist weil wir
werden ja nicht ein melting pot werden
wie die vereinigten staaten sondern wir
werden ja unsere geschichten unsere
sprachen unserer kulturen beibehalten
und unsere staaten beibehalten aber im
föderalen sinne ansonsten funktioniert
das ganze nicht und wir sehen ja auch
einen us lange weiter
schauen sie sich mal unsere welt an wer
sind denn die mit denen wir uns
auseinanderzusetzen haben das sind nicht
unsere nachbarn her in europa sondern
das sind morgen china indien der
südostasiatische raum und wenn wir da
nicht auf augenhöhe mit denen reden
werden wir untergebuttert das ist klar
und deutlich wie das amen in der kirche
also dann wissen wir damit die nächste
generation noch hier in europa bei sich
zu hause bleibt und entscheiden kann was
bei sich zuhause geschieht müssen wir
dass europa so stärken dass es sich auf
weltebene durchsetzen kann
trotzdem haben sie gewichtige eu
kritiker die sich jetzt gerade im mai
gut durchgesetzt haben in den wahlen als
gesamtergebnis bei 6,3 im parlament also
diese diese eine fraktion europa der
freiheit unserer direkten demokratie
eine fraktion die sich zwar für
demokratie einsetzt aber stark auch für
den nationalstaat gegen war sie
zentralisierung in prüfend brüsten für
mehr föderalismus und die oft auch
gerade in ihrer eigenen staaten die eu
sehr frontal angreift welche bedeutung
hat diese fraktion haben diese parteien
im europäischen parlament
weder salopp ausgedrückt aber dann
erkläre ich es die machen viel radau
aber keine gesetze nun sie als
journalistin wissen was das heißt hat
auch machen wenn man in diesem großen
parlament sitzt wo 75 80 prozent der
gewählten volksvertreter gesetze machen
wollen sich einbringen um dieses
kontinent aufzubauen auf die eine oder
andere art und weise da sitzen ja viele
politische ansichten zusammen
dann kommen die anderen und dem machen
klammert die kameras richten sich immer
auf die klamauk machen
es wird zusehends schwieriger ruhig
überlegt am gesetzesvorhaben zu arbeiten
aber gut das ist die demokratie wir
haben die die sitzen da gewählte
volksvertreter also muss man ihnen auch
zu hören aber bewirken in der praxis auf
den gesetzen dicken die haben ja nicht
die dient die masse um
gesetzesänderungen einzubringen die
gesetzesänderungen werden in der
massiven mitte dieses parlaments gemacht
an welchem punkt müssen sie diese
kritiker ernst nehmen nicht die kritiker
aber die menschen die die kritiker
gewählt haben warum werden die gewählt
irgendwie aus furcht aus angst da ändert
sich was was wir nicht mehr
kontrollieren
es ist auch einfacher hinzugehen mit
populistischen tönen was können sie ja
auch in diesem schönen land leider mit
populistischen tönen
ohne erklärungen und ohne aufbau die
massen hinter sich zu bekommen und das
ist genau das gefährliche und deshalb
genau aus der ursache habe ich ja diese
bürger veranstaltungen organisiert
hoffend dass die nationalpolizei wieder
das übernehmen werden
denn wir müssen in die diskussion kommen
wenn jemand mir eine frage stellt in
einer solchen bürgeranhörung dann muss
ich natürlich klar und deutlich auf
diese frage antworten ich merke ja auch
immer in meinen versammlungen dass wenn
man sich die zeit nimmt den menschen zu
antworten und zu argumentieren dass man
dann den menschen auf seine seite zieht
das ist eine sache des vertrauens aber
vertrauen kann man nicht von oben nach
unten dekretieren vertrauen muss von
unten nach oben aufgebaut werden und das
ist nicht genug geschehen und da haben
wir den salat da haben wir diese
rädelsführer
die scheint mit polizei ganz durch die
länder laufen und dann die
die sich verstehen und sie unzufrieden
hinter sich sammeln also nicht diese
menschen muss man also nicht diese
rädelsführer muss man ernst nehmen aber
die menschen die für sie gewählt haben
erinnern sie sich an eine der fragen die
hier wirklich beschäftigt hatte ich ihn
die ihm nachgegangen ist das warum der
effekte der politik ich war in einer
bürgerversammlung in thessaloniki im
norden von griechenland zurzeit
griechenland-krise inmitten der
griechenland-krise und da haben die
menschen geweint unter saß eine gruppe
von saloniki ist eine reine scheine eine
universitätsstadt eine ganze gruppe von
jungen menschen
die hatten einen sprecher und er hat mir
dann die fragen gestellt und ich bin
runter ich bin in den saal
ich hab die in die augen schaut
habt ihr in die arme genommen und habe
ihnen erklärt wie ungerecht ist
eigentlich ist weil ihre väter großväter
und urgroßväter das ganze bis beschissen
angepackt haben müssen sie jetzt drunter
leiden
aber wenn sie es nicht jetzt anpacken
und neu aufbauen werden ihre kinder und
kindeskinder noch unter denselben
problemen zu lösen so zu leiden haben
nämlich eine überaus große
administration die nicht fähig ist das
land zu administrieren sehr viel
gelder die gesteckt werden korruption
sehr viel korruption sehr wenig aufbau
alles importiert fast nichts exportiert
über die möglichkeiten gelebt und einen
haufen an schulden aufgebaut der die
nächste generation an zurückzahlen muss
und kein einkommen gesagt das kann ja
nicht funktionieren ihr könnt nicht ewig
subventionierten ihr müsst also dafür
sorgen damit das ändert und es ist
ungerecht ja und ich habe mit ihnen
geweint und das war eigentlich das
stärkste message was ich geben konnte
nicht belehrend auftreten aber erklärend
auftreten und ihnen aussagen also ich
finde es schrecklich und die politik die
ich mache und das habe ich ihnen noch
gesagt die politik die ich in europa
mache mache ich immer mit im
hinterstübchen meine 30
der inzwischen erwachsen sie das in
große jungs welche welchem kontinent
werde ich denen übergeben
wie wird das nach 20 30 jahren wenn die
in der vollen blüte stehen diese neue
generation wenn die die verantwortung in
der handeln wie wird die welt aussehen
und was tue ich heute damit die noch
selbstständig entscheiden können das ist
nämlich das was ich befürchte ich
befürchte wirklich dass wenn wir nicht
auf augenhöhe und ich glaube ich sage es
immer wieder habe es schon mehrfach
gesagt wenn wir nicht auf augenhöhe mit
den anderen kontinenten
morgen verhandeln können werden wir
untergebuttert und dann ist es vorbei
mit dem schlaraffenland euro war denn
wir sind einschlagen schlafen land trotz
aller krisen und probleme den ds nun mal
gibt und die wir überbrücken müssen
wie sieht denn dieses europa für sie in
20 jahren aus das ist eine föderation
nach das sind die vereinigten staaten
von europa nach europäischem muster wie
ich gesagt habe also kein melting pot
das keine gleichschaltung mit der
kulturellen vielfalt mit den diesen
gewachsenen historien die wir haben aber
wir werden dann eine starke gemeinsame
außenpolitik haben sogar
höchstwahrscheinlich und das kommt als
prozedere normalerweise hinzu eine art
europäische armee wir werden in
wirtschaftsfragen eine absolute
gleichschaltung der bestimmungen haben
dass ein gesetz eine wirtschaftspolitik
eine ein gesetz für ein kontinent was
ich ja auch in verschiedenen meiner
gesetzgebung immer versucht habe zu
machen
damit das funktioniert schauen sie wir
sind die größte wirtschaftsmacht der
welt größer als die vereinigten staaten
von amerika nur die sind stärker als wir
warum weil wir ja noch immer dieser 8
fsi allen grenzen in unserem auf unserem
markt haben und die müssen weg wir
brauchen ein gutes starkes kontinent und
erst dann werden meine söhne auf
augenhöhe mit den chinesen mit den
indern den amerikanern sowieso morgen
noch reden können und welches ist das
narrativ dass diego in diese richtung
lenkt ich meine dass alternativ dieses
fried dieser friedensstifterin das ist
historisch richtig aber man hat ja auch
gemerkt dass hat an bedeutung verloren
kommt dieses narrativ jetzt wieder
angesichts beispielsweise
auseinandersetzung mit russland es ist
eine tatsache dass die art und weise wie
man mir europa erklärt hat ich komme aus
chance als ich klein war als ich ihm
aufwachsen war als ich ihm lernen war
gerne heute noch immer aber als ich in
diesen jugendjahren war da kam luxemburg
aus der deutschen annexion wir hatten
nach den polen prozentual gesehen die
größten verluste an
also wir hatten wirklich zweiten
weltkrieg das war ganz schlimm
und da haben wir gesagt wir müssen haupt
aber sonst werden wir wieder als kleines
land bekommt wir müssen europa waren und
deshalb fahren die luxemburger auch
immer in der ersten reihe um das zu tun
und das haben wir ja auch verstanden
weil wir aus diesen horror geschichten
heraus kamen nur sehen eine eine nette
geschichte aber die erklärt alles in
meiner küche wird gekocht das tue ich
und die jungs bringen die kollegen mit
die sitzen rund um den tischen dann wird
diskutiert
da haben die diskutiert über die mauer
und berlin
wir haben dann geplant einen 34 teilen
nach berlin zu gehen ich fand das sehr
gut und ich war auch gut dass sie über
die mauer reden dann hab ich denn dann
erzählt wie damals mit gorbatschow und
kohl
da hat mein sohn mich angeschaut hat
gesagt mama ist eine diskothek okay
und da habe ich einmal geschluckt und
gesagt ja die sind ja nach dem mauerfall
geboren
für die hat dieser fall der mauer und
das ein kontinent sich mit sich selbst
wieder versöhnt hat doch nicht denselben
wert als für mich und da ist mir
eigentlich ein gefallen also wir
brauchen ein neues narrativ für diese
neue generationen mit den alten
geschichten das ist wo kleopatra gutes
interessant aber ansonsten nicht so
schrecklich weil sie ist das ist die
globalisierung das was ich gesagt habe
die augenhöhe
diese neue generation ist ja eine
generation die sehr viel reist die über
den tellerrand wächst normalerweise
jedenfalls jedenfalls die die stark sind
und das ganze führen werden und die
werden
diese föderation aufbauen weil sie sehen
dass es nicht anders geht weil die auch
bei sich zu hause ja noch eine stimme
haben wollen und nicht von außen her
jemand der ihnen etwas auferlegt denn
wenn die noch eigenständig sein wollen
müssen sie stark sein groß sein
ein kontinent eine regel und ich die die
mithalten können auf weltebene also
globalisierung interessiert sie sehr
stark die kriege auch hier rund um uns
sind und die flüchtlinge die zu uns
kommen die jungen leute haben ja ein
sehr starkes menschliches verständnis
für die jungen flüchtlingskinder die bei
ihnen in der schule sind zum beispiel
dieses verständnis von gerechtigkeit
die probleme die die erwachsenen damit
sehen wir werden jetzt überrannt von
sehen die jugendlichen eigentlich in
schüleralter im studentenalter nicht auf
dieselbe art und weise und die dann
heran zu führen wie gehen wir mit diesen
menschen die ja anders sind anders
denken eine andere kultur haben als wir
wie gehen wir mit denen um und die
höheren denen ja auch manchmal zu und
dann wissen die wo die herkommen was die
mitgemacht haben ehe sie in frieden
einen ruhigen platz finden konnten
das r steht die jugend viel besser als
wir und das ist eine hoffnung für die
zukunft
was würden diese jungen von ihnen
erwarten im zusammenhang mit den
flüchtlingen in italien hoch ich finde
das schrecklich ich auch sie auch nur
wie macht man das
es kommen ja immer mehr und wir können
ja unmöglich alles elend der welt auf
dem europäischen kontinent dem dem
helfen
und deshalb ist der ansatz den wir
machen auf in den ursprungsländern
ungemein wichtig und deshalb ist auch
die nachbarschaftspolitik die wir neben
unserer außenpolitik aufgebaut haben
indem wir investieren in unsere
nachbarländer damit die sich
demokratisch entwickeln können und nicht
in st
die horrorszenarien ausufern wie eben
der nahe osten und afrika in diesem
augenblick sich darstellen und dann
haben diese jungen menschen auch
verständnis dafür dass man das macht
wenn man die kausalität dann zusammen
stellt aber dass unrechts gefühl ist
sehr stark papst
franziskus war im europa parlament und
hat ja klare worte geredet da haben
meine jungs gesagt also hast du dem
zugehört jetzt mach mal was der gesagt
hat so einfach geht es natürlich in der
politik auch nicht aber dieses abwägen
zwischen einerseits menschlichkeit und
das verdammte die verdammte pflicht die
wir haben den die menschen die vor
terror tun krieg fliehen denen eine
bleibe zu geben und das macht die
schweiz doch auch da gibt es doch keinen
unterschied dass man aber wie viele
können das sein
jetzt sind wir abgekommen von der
normalen zuwanderung wie sie das nennen
oder europäische bürger haben die
freizügigkeit rede
jetzt sind wir wirklich bei denen die
vor krieg und elend befreien und leider
werden es immer mehr
wir haben auch vielleicht verpasst
kollektiv uns genug einzusetzen damit
diese kollektiven horrorszenarien wie
wir sitzt sehen damit die am anfang
gebremst werden und nicht erst wenn
alles zu ende ist man mit europa eine
lösung haben europa arbeitet ja an
dieser lösung ist übrigens interessant
zu sehen wie schnell sich eine
europäische außenpolitik aufgebaut hat
das war ja verpönt vor einigen jahren
war ja jeder außenminister eines
nationalstaates selber glänzen wollte
heute hat man verstanden dass man zwar
noch national selber glänzen kann
aber wenn man es nicht gemeinsam
hinkriegt
dann glänzt man nicht mehr lange
national und aus der not heraus den
aufbau den schnellen aufbau dieser
europäischen außenpolitik ist eines der
phänomene die interessant sind
das muss noch ganz kurz auf ihre jungen
zurückkommen die sind wichtig für die
zukunft europas werden wir die werden
sie die begeistern können und zwar nicht
nur die die mit erasmus in europa herum
reißen sondern auch die anderen die
vielleicht weiter weg sind
da muss man auch viel investieren in
diskussionen
meine persönliche erfahrung mit den
jungen leute nicht immer die kommen
manchmal sehr gelangweilt daher hören
würde ich dann anfange über europa zur
einer europäerin
ich habe noch nie solche gesehen die
gelangweilt wieder nach zwei stunden
wieder gegangen sind
sie sind man muss sie auch begeistern
kann schauen sie mal das ist ja auch der
politiker sind ja keine neu drin
wir müssen ja fähig sein
unsere vision der zukunft unsere
begeisterung unsere erklärung warum wir
das jetzt tun müssen und unsere
überzeugungen auch um die an die
menschen ran zu bringen
ich wünsche mir sehr oft mehr
überzeugungskraft der europäischen
politiker und welchen platz würden sie
sich für die schweiz in europa menschen
also sie haben es doch schon gesagt die
schweiz in europa wie beim training ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch gern
geschehen
nächste woche spricht meine kollegin
barbara bleisch mit der amerikanischen
star philosophin martha nussbaum
es geht um die fragen warum politik
gefühle braucht und warum es ohne
mitgefühl keine gerechtigkeit gibt
[Musik]